dramatic Rescue of U.S embassy Personnel
from Sudan amid Fierce fighting between
two factions of the country's military
conditions rapidly getting worse food
and fuel getting hard to find it's a
horrific term for the capital city of
Africa's third largest country and what
happens next could have Global
implications Deborah patta is following
Oliver forest from West Africa
good morning as the Sudanese Army under
rival paramilitary group were battling
it out for power in the country's
capital the U.S was drawing up a daring
plan to rescue its Embassy staff Court
in the crossfire
this is what cartoon has looked like for
more than a week
gunshots ringing out in residential
areas fighter jets thundering across
apartment blocks and an International
Airport engulfed in flames
despite the Declaration of a ceasefire
over the weekend there was no guarantee
it would hold it was into this perilous
conflict that U.S Special Forces were
getting ready to execute their Dangerous
Mission departing from here Camp
lemonier the American Military Base in
the Horn of Africa's strategic nation of
Djibouti flying 1 600 miles to
khartoumen back to Rescue their
diplomats on Saturday Chinook
helicopters took off from lemonier
refueling in Ethiopia Landing in the
Sudanese Capital late that night it took
less than an hour to airlift just under
100 people from the U.S compound before
they headed back via Ethiopia to
Djibouti the staff were then flown to
Ramstein in Germany
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinker
no doubt breathing a sigh of relief as
he monitored their progress for the
people of this country caught up in the
violence there is no quickest game
better Rivals generals burhan and hamdan
have turned cartoon a city of over 6
million people into a personal Battle
Zone triggering a humanitarian crisis
and raising the Specter of a prolonged
and deadly Civil War
there are still hundreds of private
American citizens inside Sudan asking
for help the U.S has said while it is
committed to assisting them it is
currently not safe for a coordinated
evacuation Gail
thank you very much Deborah